and when somebody you know is going to
disappear sometimes you got to think of
something that will make people cry hey
youtubers it's Charlie and there's been
a lot of stuff going on in the Marvel
Universe this past week so I thought I'd
do a video I'm talking about killing
Avengers and the real villain of
guardians of the galaxy so the story
goes that Joss Whedon is obsessed with
death and the Avengers franchise right
now he spent the whole first part of the
year talking about Agent Coulson coming
back and now he wants to kill off a core
Avenger I don't know about the idea of
killing a character off especially on a
major franchise like Avengers with this
big sequel age of Ultron coming but the
idea the true death is really
interesting in the Marvel Universe they
tried this in the comic books by killing
Captain America during Civil War but
obviously they brought him back at the
end so how do we take the idea of
killing off a core Avenger seriously
Whedon said that the only way Marvel
would let him kill off a core Avenger is
if that character had zero potential
first spin-off that's right we're
talking hundreds of millions of dollars
for these spin-offs so obviously the
character would not have to have
anything coming and that really narrows
the field a little bit and when it's all
said and done maybe the true death in
the Marvel Universe is just sitting out
a phaser - well let's talk about who's
gonna get the short end of the stick in
age of Ultron so after you narrow down
the choices based on that criteria that
Joss Whedon mentioned you basically have
two choices Black Widow and Hawkeye no
spin-offs have been announced for either
character and the relatively minor while
at the same time being core Avengers
that is being part of that first
Avengers team so following that line of
logic let's eliminate one more person
black widow that's right there's no way
that Marvel would let age of Ultron turn
into a major sausagefest or any future
Avengers sequels
so obviously that character that's
probably going to die would have to be
Hawkeye so why don't I think it's going
to be Hawkeye let's look at some of the
evidences past year most of the
conversations about the future of the
Marvel Universe have revolved around the
future of Robert Downey jr. in the
Marvel Universe but there's also been a
lot of conversations happening about the
role of Hawkeye in the future a lot of
people felt that Hawkeye was really a
sideline in that first movie and with
Jeremy Renner's career really taking off
it looked like he wasn't going to appear
in any of these Avengers sequels but
Joss Whedon came out and said he's going
to be a huge part of age of Ultron and
doesn't that just feel like a Joss
Whedon thing to do you give a sideline
character a much bigger part in a new
story then
you quietly hire two new actors to fill
a hole whenever that character leaves
I'm talking about Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch who are also Avengers in
the comic books I really do feel like
Joss Whedon is going to give Hawkeye
really big part in age of Ultron but
then he's just gonna pull the rug right
out from under him well let me know what
you think is just Whedon going to kill
one of the core Avengers in age of
Ultron remember there's certain criteria
no spin-offs and it has to be core
Avenger if it doesn't end up being
Hawkeye then it could be Quicksilver
Scarlet Witch they are kind of red
shirts and the Marvel franchise right
now at least in the movie franchise so
that's basically what a red shirt is the
brand-new character who's squishy goes
on his first mission and boom but if you
want to grow a franchise you can't keep
killing off brand new characters so I
don't think it's gonna be either one of
them let me know what you think but I
think the evidence really does point to
Hawkeye on the other side of the Marvel
Universe Kevin Feige was talking a lot
about the role of Fei knows and the true
villain of guardians of the galaxy so
what he said is that Thanos will be a
much bigger presence in guardians of the
galaxy than he was at the end of that
Avengers movie but that he won't be the
main villain that will actually go to
Lee paces Ronan the accuser and while in
the comic books that character goes from
being bad to being good I don't think
that's what's going to happen in
guardians of the galaxy that's just
because Feige said that zoe saldana
'he's gomorrah actually goes from being
bad to being good that's right she
starts out the movie with Ronan the
accuser and then through the process of
the movie becomes a guardian so the
movie is a bit of a redemption arc for
her I do think that they're going to set
anything up in this guardians of the
galaxy movie it'll be the idea of Nova
now Glenn Close was playing Nova prime
so the Nova Corpse are in the movie but
I do think that Marvel will do a Nova
movie at some point so obviously that
idea has to be teased during this movie
so big news tomorrow I'll be talking
about Christopher Nolan and the flash
movie and the flash TV series be sure to
subscribe to get that video I'll also be
doing a preview for The Walking Dead
Season four divergent and I'll be
teasing a big new Game of Thrones Season
four series that I'm working on I'll
announce later this week when I'm going
to start posting that Game of Thrones
series because it's gonna take a little
bit more work if you really want to help
me out then like and share this video
you can click here to learn all about
Bradley Cooper joining guardians of the
galaxy and you can click here to watch
Tom Hiddleston talk all about Loki it
does these
three thanks so much see you guys
tomorrow high fives